you know what I was reminded of that
Michael Jordan actually when I was
watching that Michael Jordan documentary
yeah that he did Saturday Night Live did
you work with him so I did one sketch
with him he came in he was very very
cool I didn't want to bug him you know
he's meeting 50 people he's no reason to
meet me he remember me but I was in a
sketch where we were all white guys and
we didn't want him on our basketball
team because he was black it was like in
the 50s and we were like who wants this
guy and they're like he's really good
you know as a coach like in the 50s and
the announcer was Rob Schneider guy I'm
dribbling around he's really giving the
referee the business and then at
halftime we're like hey we don't want
you in the team anymore we won't say
it's cuz he's black like it's just it's
not fitting in here and it was me Mike
Meyers and Adam and they're all kicking
him off and he goes so you all want me
to leave and he goes even you peewee and
I go like this
we wrote off a petition to get you off
the team and everyone signed it peewee
you to look at this picture I found
Howard you want me to show you yeah show
me sure would be good this was an old
SNL picture is that kind of fun to see
so when you're a writer you're new and
they don't like you that much they make
you do promos so I had a right friend
but that was the funnest job because you
walk in that there's Phil as Clinton
Perry was the host and then make Jagger
was music and Lorne is in the background
what a great picture I remember that was
during a February sweeps run where
McCartney was the music Madonna was
music and I think Alec Baldwin was one
of the hosts and Tom Hanks was with us
so it was like fad run big ratings
everybody's great and then I do promos
so and they think I'm the best writer
but they don't realize they give the
worst writer problems so I go up there
and I'm like Tom I feel this you should
be like you know more of it I don't feel
like coming out of you and then they're
like [ __ ] [ __ ] tell me what to do
and then Lauren's back there these are
you know number one